All the information you need is in the Course wiki,
which you can get to by clicking this icon, found
at the top of this screen. In the wiki, hopefully
you'll find some information that you find useful. For example,
here's a Course Index. If you forget what a construct
is, you can click here to review the definition of
constructs. You'll also see a Course Schedule if you're taking
the class for credit with San Jose State University. If
you're not taking the class for credit, then
you don't need to worry about adhering to any
deadlines. But if you are, it's better to
click on it and see when everything is due.
The class officially ends August 9th. You'll also
see an Exam Resources page. This tells you the
dates of the exams. And again, this is only
for students taking the course for credit with San
Jose State University. This also gives you resources for
the exam, such as a study guide and practice
exam. And importantly, it tells you how to register
for the proctored exams. So feel free to read
ahead, if you have time. So now if you'd like, click the wiki and explore.
You're done with this orientation lesson. And we
hope you're really excited to take the class.